J'ai toujours pensé qu'un jour je perdrais
beaucoup de choses à perdre est perdue est perdue
la jeunesse est perdue la beauté est
perdre même des amis des gens qui
ils vont et viennent dans ta vie mais la voix
Je n'ai jamais pensé que c'était quelque chose qui pourrait
disparaissent et quand et quand il y avait ces
des moments de doute où je ne savais pas si j'allais
pouvoir chanter à nouveau un jour
temps, eh bien, c'était vraiment un autre moment
noir de ma vie
[Musique]
Yo
à
[Musique]
et
Yo
quand j'avais 15 ans tous les vendredis avec mon
école nous sommes allés
pour éduquer les enfants de ce
quartier qui n'avait pas accès à l'éducation
donc tous les vendredis
nous avons essayé d'apprendre à lire et à écrire
mais c'était tellement frustrant la la la
le sentiment de ne pas vraiment pouvoir faire
en plus pour eux on n'en avait pas assez
matériel scolaire
nous avons dû nous asseoir dehors
les maisons sur le sol lui-même dans la boue
pratiquement pour leur enseigner
voyelles aux enfants qui allaient pieds nus
sale
[Musique]
m
Michelle, fan du consensus de Vigo
j le monde
droits de l'homme réservés vie guerres
[Musique]
déterminer 99 direct parfois c'est facile
diviser le témoin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
J'ai une relation avec le football
assez spécial je pense que le football a
changé ma vie à bien des égards
la coupe du monde a changé ma vie depuis
d'une manière particulière en 2010
J'ai rencontré l'amour de ma vie à travers
coupe du monde afrique du sud
Et si ce n'était pas pour cette coupe du monde, non
mon fils serait ici avec moi aujourd'hui
[Musique]
en ce moment c'est beaucoup plus facile et c'est
Il est vrai que la musique latine vit une
moment de grande réceptivité et bien il y a
en profiter car très bien
artistes là-bas qui veulent être
entendu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oh
[Musique]
est beaucoup de choses se sentent
si quelqu'un m'avait dit quand je vivais
à barranquilla colombie qui allait être
ici un jour chantant au superbowl
qu'est-ce que je pense
l'un des événements les plus importants
mondial
peut-être que je ne l'aurais pas cru